♪ (music) ♪
Welcome to the best day of the year!
Welcome to day three of Next.
This is it. This is my favorite part.
This is the Developer Keynote.
Excited? Got some developers in the room?
(cheers)
Alright. We're going to have
a lot of fun today.
A lot of code. A lot of demos.
But I thought I'd start...
... Let's get to know each other.
Sound good?
So let's get a show of hands.
Let's really do this.
Who's a developer in the room?
Raise your hand if you're a developer.
(cheers)
Alright.
How about operators?
We love our operators, too.
Got some operators in the room.
How about some language stuff.
Any Java developers?
(cheers)
Yeah, I've got a lot of Java developers.
Node.js?
(cheers)
Wow! A lot of Node.js.
Gophers? Go!
(cheers)
Gophers, love them some go.
Okay. Let's see where you work.
Who's with an enterprise, big company?
Yeah.
(cheering and laughter)
Well done.
Startups?
(laughter)
Okay, this is important.
Is anyone looking for a job?
(laughter)
This guy right here. Okay.
Talk to all those people around you.
They're hiring.
So we'll get you set up.
Look, it's a great time to be a developer.
Every industry is changing, right?
Software is right in the middle
of a lot of those changes.
And you, the developers,
you're right in the heart of it.
You're driving all that.
And think about the tools that you use.
The tools that we use
are changing every day also.
Open source has been just a huge part
of that transformation.
Think about it.
When's the last time
you actually set up a server?
That's an API call now.
How about configured
an operating system image?
You don't do that, right?
That's all containers.
It's all just a library
of container images now.
How about set up a whole fleet?
Do you set up a whole fleet,
or do you Terraform it?
Right? That's the way it works now.
So the other thing that I think
is a really interesting change
is the very role of a developer is changing.
You don't just write code.
You're working with big data.
You're working with event streams
and IoT data.
You're starting to do data science
and machine learning.
Who's written their first
machine learning app so far?
Yeah, it's just emerging.
It's super exciting to help you all
go on this journey together.
You're getting to know your users,
you're doing user experience.
You're managing products, not just projects.
And, ultimately, you're working as a team
to ship great experiences
out to users and customers.
And I think
that's a pretty amazing change.
Now, cloud is enabling all this.
We're all sort of on this journey
to evolve together to this new world.
We all have access
to this amazing technology.
You can just get it as a service.
Everything is available as a service.
So I'm pretty sure the next five years
are going to be even more exciting
than the last five years.
To tell that story, we wanted to talk
to some community members,
get some voices from our community.
Any community members here in the room
from the Google developer communities
out around the world?
Right on!
(loud cheering)
Okay, we made a little video
to show you some of their stories
and some of the things they're working on.
So with that, I'm going
to roll a little video for you.
♪ (music) ♪
Funny enough,
we started with a simple conversation.
So, imagine it's election day.
Thirty, forty million people
showing up to vote.
What our software does is allow them
to register these people,
check for duplicates
or if there are any signs of fraud.
(Akanksha) We have a loyalty program
where an average person can earn points
every time they shop for groceries,
and this currency effectively becomes
a second source of wealth
to pay for everything
from your electricity bill
to school fees and doctors' bills.
Two of my cousin's sisters
suffered from breast cancer,
and I ended up losing them.
That's when I thought,
"We need to do something with technology,
to build a new way
of doing breast cancer screening.
(Piyali Dey) In my graduate school,
I was one of two women in a class of 45.
And it kind of got me thinking
that this is not what it's supposed to be.
(Rafael Figueroa) We have
this patient called Maria.
She is six years old.
And she was having these daily seizures.
She lived in a remote area in Brazil
where there are no specialists.
And no one in the city could help her.
(Amanda Cavallaro) I'm a developer
during the day,
But then during the evening
I wear my cape, and I do Google stuff.
(Femi) One of the things that is most amazing
is being on Google Cloud has enabled us
to be online and available 100% of the time
with automated health checks,
security checks, and logs monitoring.
I use tools like Stackdriver
to keep me on top of all of that.
(Akanksha) Google and the Android platform
have become kind of a backbone
of our entire product ecosystem,
where we could actually
build this loyalty program
powered by mobile phones.
We use deep learning
and the technology stack called TensorFlow
to interpret thermography,
which basically measures
the temperature on the chest
and then figures out if there is
any abnormal tissue activity.
And this can be five to eight years
before a lump is formed or felt.
We're actually helping people
to get access to doctors
that they couldn't have without the stack.
For example, this case with Maria--
with Google Cloud,
we connect to the clinic device,
measure Maria's brainwaves,
send to the best
child neurologist in the country,
3,000 kilometers away, in São Paulo,
and she found a cure for Maria.
And this was awesome.
I run the Google Developer Group,
Vancouver chapter.
I see girls from high school.
They actually show up at our meetups.
They know nothing about the product,
and after like one hour,
or two hours of time,
they can build something from scratch.
(Amanda) I'm one of the co-organizers
of GDG Cloud, London.
We are the most active
GDG Cloud community in the world,
and I love how you can achieve
all these dreams and passions
and ideas you have
using the Google Cloud platform.
Whatever you do in life,
try to solve a meaningful problem.
More than ever,
people are asking for a purpose
in the work that they do.
You're not just building product,
you're building product
that can change people's lives.
My hope is that we will excel in technology,
women will get their seats at the table.
I feel that Google just empowered me.
>From that moment, it's been love.
It's pure love.
♪ (music) ♪
(cheers and applause)
So cool!
Thank you.
Thank you Amanda, and Femi,
and all the community members.
So great to hear your stories.
So look, we're going to kick off today.
We're going to have a great day.
But I really wanted to start
with a promise to you,
a promise that Google is going
to really do three things.
The first is continue
to deliver amazing innovation--
things like AutoML and TPUs,
silicon for TensorFlow at massive scale.
The second thing we're going to do
is we're committed to open source
and an open cloud.
You know, Google's got
about 20 years of experience
doing open source and being part
of the open source community
under our belts, and we're looking forward
to doing the next 20 years with you.
And then the third thing
is that community theme,
and we wanted to really launch that
at this conference.
We believe in being part
of the developer community.
We are engineers at Google.
We sit all over the world with all of you.
And we want to continue
to be really connected with you
as we figure out
this next generation of technology.
So, for the rest of the morning
we have one simple rule,
and that is: "Show, don't tell."
We've got a lot of great code.
It's going to be a lot of fun.
And let's get started, yeah? Right on!
I want to introduce
a great executive at Google,
a Vice-President of Engineering,
Melody Meckfessel,
is going to talk to you about tools.
Thanks!
(applause)
♪ (music) ♪
Thanks so much, Adam.
I'm so happy to be here today.
My name's Melody Meckfessel,
and I'm passionate about developers
because I am one.
And I also worked
for many years in operations,
where I carried a pager.
And I became very familiar with the phrase,
"It works well on my machine."
So I lead developer
and operator tools at Google.
This includes Google engineers,
Chrome and Open Source developers,
Android developers, and developers
using Google's Cloud Platform.
Now, each one of us probably has
a different definition of DevOps.
At Google, our understanding
is that DevOps includes two things:
end-to-end automated tooling--
from source, to build-and-test,
to releasing with integrated observability--
and the culture that supports
and enables developers.
DevOps is near and dear to my heart,
because it's about automating away the toil
while empowering the humans.
It makes us productive,
and maybe just a little bit happy.
So how many humans in the room today?
(cheers)
Yeah?
(laughs) I hope so!
Well, humans develop software
and operate services.
And at Google, we've spent
a significant effort
understanding productivity.
Different developers need
different levels of insight and care.
And, as developers,
we want to choose the best DevOps tools
to get our work done.
But that choice can be hard sometimes.
Imagine being a new developer
and having to pick your language
or framework that you need to use.
Or where to deploy your app--
VM, Kubernetes.
Or which cloud platform to use.
Well, that one should be easy, right?
Google Cloud Platform.
(chuckles) That's why we're here!
And with so many choices at every stage,
selecting the right DevOps tools
can be overwhelming
and waste our time.
At Google, our goal is to make
these DevOps tooling decisions
easier for you.
That way you can go back
to doing what you love--writing code,
and bringing your idea to life quickly.
But moving fast shouldn't come
at the expense of security or stability,
because without that,
any speed improvements are useless.
Industry research shows
that high-performing DevOps teams
achieve both faster releases
and better stability.
They deploy 46 times more frequently
than their low-performing peers.
And their production deployments
are seven times less likely
to result in a degraded service.
So think about that.
You get faster releases
with better stability.
And what explains this behavior?
Well, it comes back to this combination
of end-to-end tooling
and the DevOps culture.
At Google we've embraced and adopted
DevOps cultural principles.
First, use data to guide your decisions.
Dig into the code,
look at logs, look at traces,
to understand what's going on.
Have a shared fate and collaboration
between the humans--
the developers and operators--
because we know we're more powerful
when we work together.
Choose transparency over secrecy and siloing.
Everyone sees the same data and information
by integrating observability into your apps.
And, finally, embrace blameless postmortems
to encourage continuous improvement
within your teams.
We have to accept and learn from our failure.
I mean, this is software development, right?
We're going to have bugs.
So all of this is super easy to say,
but when you live it, it's magic.
This is how we build trust
between developers and operators.
We have to trust each other
to make it happen for our users.
So I want to show you, today,
end-to-end DevOps tooling
to help you build, deploy,
and monitor your apps
quickly and safely.
Our DevOps tools consist
of Cloud Source Repositories--
a single place to store,
manage, and track your code;
Cloud Build, a fully managed
continuous integration and delivery platform
that lets you build and test
your applications in the cloud
at any scale;
and Stackdriver--management tools
for developers and operators.
So let's walk through a day in the life
of a software developer and operator.
We're going to build
an end-to-end automated pipeline
using GCP DevOps tools
with well-known open source tools
like GitHub and Spinnaker.
We're going to go from finding
a problem in Stackdriver
to using code search functionality
in Cloud Source Repositories
to find the code.
We're going to fix the code.
We're going to commit the change to GitHub.
We're going to kick off a build
using Cloud Build.
And then we're going to deploy
to GKE using Spinnaker.
And we're going to do all that
in just 10 minutes.
- Morgan?
- (Morgan) Melody?
Awesome to see you!
(Morgan) Great to see you here.
Hello everybody.
(Melody) Alright! So let's get started!
(applause)
So this is Hipstershop.
You may remember it from Tuesday's keynote.
We're going to purchase an item.
(Morgan) And it is a lot slower
than it was on Tuesday.
Yeah, I think it's popularity increased
over the last two days.
So we're going to start our investigation
looking at Stackdriver Trace,
which is part of our APM Suite.
Our APM Suite lets you do
production debugging, profiling,
and tracing on applications running anywhere.
And with Google Ed projects like OpenCensus
we're making it incredibly easy
to extract telemetry from your applications,
whatever tools you decide to use.
So after looking at some traces
we see a couple of things.
First, for a single customer request,
we see many child requests.
So we're just going to batch those up.
It's going to make it more efficient.
But the second thing that we notice here
is that the requests to the catalog service
are incredibly...
... Whoa! Very slow!
(Morgan) This one's about 2.6 seconds,
just for one of them.
Okay, well we're going
to have to dig in on this.
So we're going to go from Stackdriver Trace
to Stackdriver Profiler,
which profiles applications continually
with no appreciable overhead.
We've been using Profiler
at Google for many years,
and now our customers get to use
the same functionality.
So this icicle graph,
it shows you the resources consumed
by the function on the horizontal axis
and the call hierarchy on the vertical axis.
So because things are slow,
we're going to go check out CPU time here.
And what we can see, looking at Profiler,
is that there's a really slow
GRPC GetProduct method,
which is spending all of its time
waiting on this function, parseCatalog.
I think it's taking...
... What is it now?
- (Morgan) It's 92%.
- 92%?
Yeah, it's bad.
- That's bad.
- Yeah.
That's very bad.
So let's go look at the code
for parseCatalog.
So this application code
is actually hosted on GitHub,
and it's continuously mirrored
to Cloud Source Repositories
where you can use functionality
like powerful code search and indexing.
So we're going to come here
to Cloud Source Repositories.
We're going to search
for that function we saw on Profiler.
And there it is!
(Morgan) Real quick.
(Melody) So let's take a look
at the blame layer.
Wait...
... Morgan?
Morgan?
(Morgan) You told me to slow it down.
(laughing) He's responsible for this one.
So we're going to hop to GitHub
and check out that there's a pull request
that's been created
that fixes these performance issues.
And it's for Morgan.
(Morgan) Yep. Got to fix my own bugs.
(Melody) Amazing.
(laughter)
(Melody) So I'm going to approve
the pull request from Morgan,
and this is going to automatically trigger
a Cloud Build run,
which you can see in the Cloud Build UI.
Alright! There it is!
So Zendesk, Lyft, and over 1,000 customers
use Cloud Build daily
to ship new functionality.
So, as a reminder, we're doing this all live.
The build's going to take a couple minutes,
so let's cross our fingers on this one.
At Google we create over 4 million builds
in the cloud every day
because it's flexible,
it's secure, and it scales.
But right now let's go back
and look at the pull request
that we just approved.
We can see that Cloud Build
also ran a test build
when the pull request was created.
And we did this
because we wanted to make sure
that the pull request wasn't broken.
Now, all of this is being done
through our new
Cloud Build-GitHub partnership
which we are excited to announce today.
With this partnership,
developers are able to use
Cloud Build CI capabilities
to validate changes, run tests,
and get results, right within the GitHub UI,
in a frictionless way.
So it's super easy to get started.
As long as you have a GitHub repo
with a Dockerfile in the root directory,
GitHub will automatically suggest Cloud Build
and its CI capabilities.
You can see it here.
And you can get started running builds
in just seconds.
Cloud Build makes
high-velocity software development
safe, easy, and secure.
It really unleashes your team's productivity.
So let's check the build. It's almost done.
(Morgan) Almost done.
(Melody) Hopefully.
This is where we need the DJ
to be playing a little bit of music.
One of the nice things about Cloud Build
is it shows you the logs
right in the console,
which you can see here.
And so it's finishing
the final step right now.
It's pushing it up to GCR,
and now we're done.
Alright! Live demo, folks!
(cheers)
(Melody laughs)
So all the tests passed. We're good to go.
But I keep mentioning security.
So I want to show you,
Cloud Build will actually
do security scanning for you.
So we're going to kick off a scan.
And actually it's so fast...
... We didn't find any vulnerabilities,
so we're good to deploy that.
And Morgan, if you can show an example
of maybe a past project with some...
... So you can see here
we wouldn't deploy these images
because we need to fix the issues first.
Alright, so we've done our build,
we've done our tests,
we've checked for vulnerabilities.
Cloud Build is now going to trigger
a Spinnaker pipeline
to deploy the image.
Google has been a core contributor
to the Spinnaker open source project.
This was created to make
multi-cloud deployments safe,
fast, and secure.
So today we're going to see
automated canary analysis,
which reduces the risk associated
with deploying to production.
So while we're performing
the automated canary analysis
we're going to automatically promote things,
because we don't have a lot of time today.
But what you're going to see...
... This is an actual pipeline that's running
and it has three stages.
In the first stage,
the canary build is pushed
to a single instance of the app
and some traffic is routed to it.
In the second phase,
we would normally check things like metrics,
to see how it's developing,
but we've kind of automatically
pushed this forward
because it would take about 30 minutes
for us to do this task.
And in the third stage
the build will promote the canary
to all the remaining production instances.
And as you can see, the different stages--
the color turns from blue to green
as it progresses
through the canary analysis.
So I'm sure everyone here
is familiar with canary analysis itself,
but quite often when we do this
it's manual and ad hoc
and therefore it's prone
to our own human bias and error.
With Spinnaker, you can now
automatically promote
or fail the canary,
minimizing your deployment risk
while continuing to release
as fast as you possibly can.
So, assuming that these changes look good,
Spinnaker will automatically push
or roll back the canary.
Using Spinnaker,
Waze was able to create
over 1,000 production delivery pipelines
while reducing their deployment errors
by almost 95%.
That's pretty amazing.
So the deployment...
- (Morgan) ...is almost done.
- Almost done,
but we want to show you one last thing,
which is the Stackdriver Profiler has
this really great comparison feature
which lets you look
at CPU consumption patterns
that change with inversions.
And so you can see, we're running
this on some older data,
but you can see how
slow functions will shrink.
These are highlighted in blue.
So let's go back to the Spinnaker Pipeline.
(Morgan) Just a couple seconds left.
(Melody) Couple seconds left.
(Morgan) So I can show you
on this Profiler view
the parseCatalog function that was taking up
so much CPU time before,
it's now effectively fallen to zero,
which is probably where it should be.
So this comparison view lets us validate
that on that second build that we built,
even though it's from older data,
that we fixed that problem.
So let's go take a look at Spinnaker again.
Ah, it's still going.
A couple more seconds.
(Melody) A couple more seconds.
(Morgan) Now this is rolling out
on Spinnaker to, I think,
five or six different instances
on Kubernetes.
So, like Melody mentioned,
we took a canary build,
so we took over one of those instances
with the test build,
ran some checks on it.
For the purpose of this demo
we just made that always pass.
Once that passes then we go and deploy that
to the remaining instances within Kubernetes.
(Melody) Oh! It's green!
(Morgan) It's green!
(Melody) Live demo, folks. (chuckles)
(applause)
My fingers were crossed behind my back.
So let's go back to the Hipstershop,
surf around.
(Morgan) It's a lot faster.
A lot faster. Alright! There we go.
End-to-end automated tooling
using GCP DevOps.
Thanks a lot, Morgan. Awesome job.
(Morgan) Thank you, everybody.
(applause)
Alright. Well we want
to continue to collaborate
on open source tools like Bazel and Go.
And we want to work closely together
within the ecosystem.
But collaborating in the ecosystem
means being open
and working well
with the tools and technologies
that you already use today.
So I just want to take a second
and highlight two ways
that we're committed to be in the open cloud.
Terraform from HashiCorp
is a leading technology
in writing and creating
infrastructure as code.
We're committed to making first-class support
for products like Terraform.
And we have a dedicated team within Google
to support our partners like HashiCorp.
Our friends at GitLab have built
a complete open source DevOps stack.
We started working with them
a couple months ago
to integrate with GKE,
and at Next we're showing
how you can use Cloud Build
to scale your GitLab builds.
We're also helping to move GitLab.com
to run on top of GCP.
I believe that through these collaborations
within the ecosystem
we are going to make it better together.
So today you saw Stackdriver APM tools,
including Trace and Profiler.
Profiler just went to beta on GCP,
and our alpha participants
have said they were saving
about 10% of their compute bill
with less than an hour of work.
Snap was able to achieve
some pretty incredible optimizations.
You saw fast code search
using Cloud Source Repositories,
and you saw Cloud Build,
the launch of Cloud Build,
automatically run builds and tasks
in the cloud at any scale.
That included vulnerability scanning.
Shopify uses this feature
to scan over 6,000 builds a day
and 330,000 images
in the registry, every day,
and it's amazing to think about that scale.
Finally, you saw Spinnaker
help with deployments
and have awesome features
like automated canary analysis.
Businesses like HSBC, and Snap,
and eBay, and PayPal
use our DevOps tools every day
to ship new features and functionality.
We hope you will try out
these GCP tools today.
Google spent the last two decades
iterating on developer and operator tools.
Every developer and operator
deserves this level
of automation, speed, and scale.
We're even more excited about
the things that we're working on
that you're going to see in the coming year.
Let's help you focus
on the things that you love,
bringing your ideas to life.
So, next up, Kelsey Hightower's
going to do a great demo
and talk though some of the tools
that I mentioned today.
Thanks so much for your time,
and have an awesome conference.
(cheers and applause)
♪ (music) ♪
Oh, wow, this is like
an alternative Tron universe!
I've been using Kubernetes so long
I finally ended up in a container.
(laughs)
(applause)
Alright, so we've been learning
about all these new technologies--
Istio, Envoy, Kubernetes.
How do you put all these things together?
So, I work at Google,
and when I think about Google Cloud
I think about things all the way
from my laptop of my Chromebook
to the Maps API, and tools like Dialogflow.
So what I want to do is walk through
some of these things
and how I think about
putting these things together.
Now, I also want to show you
some of the tricks that I do,
so I'm going to start from the bottom
and build a weather application from zero,
starting with the database
all the way up to the endpoint.
Now, we only have about 15 minutes.
We're going to see
if we can get this all done in time.
So the first thing we're going to do
is kind of start with this example.
So here's a terminal.
Everyone likes terminals, is that cool?
(cheers and applause)
Someone's like, "Where's my GUI?"
(chuckles) We'll get there.
Alright, so what I want to do is maybe start
with a few weather locations.
So these are all of our regions in the U.S.,
our newest region being
Los Angeles, California.
And the goal is I want to take these names
and get weather data.
Now, here's a problem.
I can't just give these names
to the weather service.
I actually have to give them geocoordinates.
Now, I have a couple of options here.
I can actually use the Maps API.
The Google Cloud Maps platform
does provide a Places API
that can trade those names in
and get back some coordinates
or something close.
And then once I have those,
I can actually send those to the weather.gov,
and actually get back coordinates.
But here's the thing.
I don't have a lot of time
to write all of this code.
Now, once you become a senior engineer...
... I'm going to teach you
a couple of tricks.
Now this is what all senior engineers do.
You guys ready for the first pro tip?
Now, you've got to write some code.
This is what we do.
You do this.
If you haven't heard of Stack Overflow
(laughter)
you have no clue what's going on.
Alright, so let's do this--
google maps platform...
... This is high-quality code
that you can find on this thing, man.
Trust me.
(laughter)
And we'll do weather.
And then, okay, let's go here.
Alright, how do we do this?
Ohhhh... code!
This looks legit!
(laughter)
I'm not sure
who this Terence Ryan guy is, but...
(laughter and applause)
Now, this is the internet,
so what you've got to do
is you've got to scan
for those security vulnerabilities.
You've got to make sure this stuff is legit.
Hold on, let's make sure we can grab this
and see what we're going to do here.
So let's grab this code.
Come on! I don't care about cookies!
(laughter)
It's the internet, how dangerous could it be?
Where's my Copy and Paste?
Why are they trying to sell me stuff?
I'm trying to get my job done!
(laughter)
Oh, come on! Like the hardest part of this...
... Alright, look at these ads...
... Alright, we should be in business now.
Alright, so let's grab this.
So what you want to do is you want to scan
for security vulnerabilities
as you go through this.
That looks legit.
Talking to a database. Sure, why not?
Cool.
Let's just grab that.
So here's the thing.
Oh, I didn't grab it?
(laughter)
Golly, I should be fired!
This is why we use gists.
Alright, Copy.
So one thing is, "Good programmers copy;
great programmers paste."
(laughs)
(applause)
Alright, so we got our code.
Now the next thing we need to do
is set up a database.
Now, I am the world's most average DBA.
So, for me, I'm going to use
a hosted database service.
And I like to keep it open source,
so my favorite database is Postgres.
And what I'm going to do here...
Listen, if you're a developer
and you need to set up the database
there is no shame in clicking the button.
Click database.
Bam! Like a pro, okay?
You've got to own it! (laughs)
So I got this database set up,
and I created a user.
I actually do not know how to create a user,
so I usually click this button
because I have to look it up all the time.
So once I have the user created
I have a little .env file
so I can use natural tools.
So the thing I like about this,
I can use my existing tools to do my job.
So the first thing we're going to do here
is just get the environment variables
for my connection string in my environment.
And then we're going to see if we can connect
to the actual database, and I can.
Let's make sure we don't have
any tables set up,
so we're starting from scratch.
Now the next thing I need to do
is actually set up the database schema.
So there's some...
... SQL is dope, by the way.
If you don't know SQL, you should learn it.
Okay, so psql
and then we're going to just run
this CREATE DATABASE command.
Uh-oh, we need to get our credentials.
So pg.env
and then let's do this.
And then...
... Come on.
Uh-oh, we got a database schema.
Now let's make sure
we don't have any data in there.
Alright, we're starting from scratch.
So the next thing we're going to do
is we're going to change into that directory
where we've downloaded
that production-ready code
from the internet,
and what we're going to do
is we're going to give it credentials.
So this should be cool, legit.
This guy is a nice guy, I'm pretty sure.
So I'm going to put those credentials
in my environment.
And then what we want to do now
is just do something local.
So when I build code, I like to test locally.
I do not develop in the container.
I test things on my local machine.
So here what I want to do
is do a quick build.
And I'm using the new vgo stuff,
so I can actually do development work
without using a GOPATH.
So, for me, I'm writing everything in Golang.
And then what I'm going to do
is just build the application.
Ooh! And it compiles!
That's legit.
So let's try it. Let's see what we can do.
So, remember, the goal is
we're going to take locations,
and we want to trade them for geocoordinates
so we can then talk to the weather service.
So let's try that now.
So we'll do weather-data...
... Oh! It look like it working!
Aiite, so look it...
... This is like science, geocoordinates.
Alright, and then we're getting
the weather data.
So if everything is legit
we should be able to do a query.
And we have the weather data in our database.
Alright. So we're in business.
(cheers and applause)
Alright, now that we've got our weather data,
we need somewhere to actually run our code.
And also, if you have the idea
of running this command
from your laptop, in production, every day,
that's not how you do it.
You might want to run this code
in a cluster somewhere.
So we need some infrastructure.
So the next thing you do
is we need a Kubernetes cluster.
There's no other place better
to run your code than Kubernetes.
Marketing, I've done my job.
Alright, so... (laughs)
So here's a Kubernetes cluster,
but there's something interesting here.
So there's a couple of tricks
that I like to do.
Here's my Kubernetes cluster,
and one thing you can do
that's really nice in GCP,
you can actually have multiple node pools.
So this is the 1.10.5 cluster.
I have 13 nodes here,
but I actually have those nodes split
between two different node pools.
Now the reason why I'm doing this
is I'm using their first general pool
for my web apps,
my batch jobs, long-running services,
but this other node pool...
... I'm a big fan of Envoy.
So you've been hearing a lot about Istio,
but underneath Istio there's this nice
reverse proxy called Envoy.
And Envoy, if you can think about it,
it's like a cloud-native replacement
for Nginx or HAProxy.
It has all the things that I need
to do things like rate limiting
and timeouts and retries.
But I like to actually run Envoy
as my edge load balancer,
even in GCP.
It's the same load balancer
I run on my laptop.
So I want some parity.
So what I'm doing is I'm actually running
each of my Envoy instances
across these three nodes
using what we call a DaemonSet.
And then the last thing I do
to set up my infrastructure?
I create a load balancer
that points to just those three machines.
So if you think about it,
I have a network appliance
running inside of my cluster.
No extra hops, no iptables--
straight to Envoy
then directly to my apps.
So, with the infrastructure in place
we can start to think
about deploying our code.
So let's go back to the command line
really quickly.
So the next thing I want to do is
I don't want to execute this from my machine.
So here's a cron job.
Every five minutes it's going
to kick that code off for me automatically.
So my goal is just to push this cron Job up.
But remember, the price
of admission to Kubernetes
is a container image.
Here's my second trick that I like to do.
I have this saying,
"Don't ship build environments,
ship artifacts."
So when I build my containers
I actually just build my binaries locally,
upload the artifact,
and only have Docker package it in an image
with the scratch base image.
So my images are roughly about 7 MB.
Then watch how fast the builds are
if I do it this way.
So the first thing I'm going to do
is build that application locally,
take that binary,
push it up to Google Cloud Build,
and Cloud Build is going to do
all the work for me.
You'll notice another thing here--
I don't have Docker installed on my machine.
I can just push my builds there,
and get all of my images.
So in just a few seconds
we'll have a container image,
we're ready to go,
and then we can actually use that cron job
and Kubernetes will keep it running.
So kubectl apply -f cronjob.yaml
You'll notice there will be no pods created
until we hit that five-minute mark,
but we'll start watching
just to see when things come up.
So in about five minutes
you'll see the cron job kick off,
and Kubernetes will keep a few of them around
just in case I need to troubleshoot.
Alright, so the next thing
I'm going to do is--
we're going to move a little bit faster now--
is I need to put an API in front of this.
So what I'm going to do here is say,
kubectl apply -f
and I have this weather API service.
And then what I'm going to do here
is just deploy that.
And that's going to be a little bit faster
because I want it right now.
I already have the image
on the container registry,
it's going to pull that into the cluster,
and it's going to start running.
Now here's the next cool thing
that you can do in GKE.
We've done a lot of work
to make pods first-class citizens
inside of Google Cloud.
So you'll notice here every pod in Kubernetes
gets its own IP address.
Now the one thing that we do
is we make those IPs native,
using a technology we call IP aliases.
And what IP aliases does
is it takes all those container IPs
and makes them first-class in my VPC.
So my development box
is a VM inside of my VPC.
So what I should be able to do is actually,
without any port forwarding or extra hops,
I should be able
to make a call to my API servers
using the container IP.
And look at that.
Directly talking to the container,
using a very natural development flow
where I can work on another app
while talking to apps inside of a cluster.
That's pretty dope, if you didn't think so.
(cheers and applause)
Alright, so we're moving along here,
and the next thing we want to do
is get a web front end.
Again, you kind of have established
some patterns here.
Build a container, push it up,
and describe to Kubernetes
what you want to do.
So here we'll build our weather - frontend
and then we'll do this deployment
Now here's when things
get a little bit of interesting.
We're not going to run one copy,
we're going to let Kubernetes
run three copies
across that cluster for us.
Now once all of this running,
I have Envoy in a pre-configured IP
and a DNS address
that's pointing to this particular back end.
So what I'm going to do now is pull this up,
and we should be able
to hit the weather back end.
Oh! Things are looking good.
Let's see. Alright.
Everything seems to be working.
Now here's the thing.
I've been the sole developer this whole time.
I know the front end talks to the API server,
and the API server talks to the database,
but what happens if someone else on your team
needs to check things out?
The nice thing is I've been using OpenCensus.
So, again, I don't actually have
a service mesh,
but you can adopt
all these technologies à la carte.
So if you want to add tracing
to your application,
you can bring in tools
like the OpenCensus library,
that allows you to decorate
your function calls
or calls between apps,
and send that data to tools
like Zipkin or Jaeger.
In my case, I'm using Google Cloud,
so I'm going to send it to Stackdriver Trace.
I'm going to pop over here
to the tracing console,
and there we're going to find
one of those recent traces.
So we can see one that just came in
roughly around now,
and we'll click on it.
And you can actually see the end-to-end.
Traffic comes into the front end, the API,
and then the API returns,
but not before talking to the database.
Now here's the nice thing.
If you trace this inside of your codebase
and I click Show events,
I can come down here
and see the exact SQL query
that's being executed at that particular hop.
Now that gives you the ability
to actually see what's going on
and give people a lot more insight,
without checking out the code.
Alright, so we got
all the patterns in place--
infrastructure, tracing--
and now we need to think about something new.
Now, we only have about five minutes left
so we're going to have to simulate this.
When your boss shows up and it's like,
"Hey, we need some new functionality.
Can you get it done by Friday?"
So the task is on.
So we have this infrastructure.
We got this nice pattern set up.
And what we want to do now
is start to think about
something cool we can add in.
We've got a web front end,
but that's like so 2017.
You've got to have
a voice integration with your app
if you want to be cool.
If you can't talk to your application
you're probably doing it wrong, okay?
So what we want to do is think about
a tool called Dialogflow.
You're not going to build
your own natural-language
processing system from scratch.
Some of you are probably trying. (chuckles)
There's a better way.
So we're going to use Dialogflow.
So, again, let's walk
through the pattern really quickly.
We're going to write the application,
and then we're going to build it
and push it up.
Now remember, the container image
is just the price of admission.
So we'll build this up.
Now here's the other thing.
You won't be the sole developer
working on this application forever.
Maybe there's someone else on the team
that wants to contribute.
And maybe they have no interest
in writing YAML files
or using Kubernetes from the command line.
We've done a lot of work to make sure
that Kubernetes works well from the UI.
So we'll come over here.
We'll go to the Kubernetes console.
And we can click on Workloads.
Now notice here all the things
I did on the command line
are reflected in the GKE console.
Now, if I have a new person on the team
that's not quite familiar with Kubernetes,
this could be their workflow.
We'll click DEPLOY.
And we've done something special here.
We've integrated deeply with GCP,
including the Google Container Registry.
So if I click on this,
I can drop down and find
that image that I just created.
It finds all the right tags.
Hit SELECT.
And then it fills out
everything I need underneath.
Let's give this a name.
We'll call it the weather-assistant.
We have the right labels.
And if I have multiple clusters
I can choose where it should deploy.
If you want to see what's going on
underneath the hood,
you can actually display
that sweet, sweet YAML
that you love so much. (chuckles)
And then we also give you an autoscaler
to make sure you can respond
to traffic changes.
And we'll hit Deploy.
So that's going to do
all the heavy lifting for me
right through the UI,
and, just like that, it should be deployed.
We'll switch over here.
And we can see the weather-assistant
is now ready, serving traffic.
Now the next thing we're going to do
is make sure that we're ready
by checking the health check.
So here's the DNS name
that I've assigned to this particular app.
We'll hit it.
We see everything is working.
And we can also see all my traffic
is flowing through Envoy.
I should be in good shape.
We only have a few minutes left.
Let's see if we can pull this last piece off.
So I'm going to log in
to the Dialogflow console.
This is also part
of the Google Cloud platform.
So Dialogflow allows you to design
these voice integrations
with your application.
So we'll come here.
There's a couple things we need to do.
First, we need to make sure
that our users have a good time
with our application,
so what we're going to do
is we're going to define
all these verified inputs
and create a few synonyms,
just in case they want
to say things like, "Los Angeles,"
or "Los Angeles, California, USA"
to talk to the weather app.
The next thing we're going to do
is describe their intent.
What does our user want to do?
So here we want to have them
check the temperature.
Now there's no way I'm going to define
everything or every phrase
our users would do.
So here what I'm going to do
is give Dialogflow
a few training phrases.
And notice how it's automatically
pulling out those regions
that match the entities
that I described before.
So we're ready to go.
Now I want to send this to our webhook
that we just got deployed.
So we'll come here.
We have a couple more steps.
We'll go to Fulfillment.
And from Fulfillment you'll see
that I'm just putting in
that same URL that I had earlier
that's pointing to my Kubernetes stack.
Alright?
You have all kinds of integrations
that you can do,
but this time we just want to do
the Google Assistant.
Now this whole time I've been using
my Pixelbook to do this demo,
and this is something
that's also, I think, a part
of the end-to-end experience at Google.
So we want to test out this.
Now, I could use a simulator,
or I could actually come down here
and use my laptop.
Now, to prove that this is real,
we're going to look at the logs
for the Assistant
to make sure Kelsey isn't cheating.
So kubectl logs
we'll give it that container name,
and we can just stream the logs here.
So we can see it's listening
but there's nothing there yet.
So if I hit the Assistant button
on my Pixelbook
we should be able to talk to this thing.
Yeah, whatever.
Alright. "Talk to the local weather service."
(Google Assistant) Sure, here's
the test version of local weather.
(chime)
Hello, Kelsey.
(Kelsey) Hello!
(Google Assistant) Looks like you have
a pretty large crowd here.
I hope the demo gods are on your side.
(cheers and applause)
(Kelsey) I hope so, too!
Alright, so let's give this a go.
What's the current temperature
in Los Angeles, California?
(Google Assistant) The current temperature
in Los Angeles, California, USA is 82℉
(Kelsey) Thank you.
(Google Assistant) Okay, I gotta admit.
That was pretty dope.
(laughter and applause)
And with that you kind of saw
the end-to-end Google experience.
Starting with my laptop
all the way to the data model,
I can use open source tools
like Cloud SQL, Postgres.
Then I can actually use
the industry-standard Kubernetes,
backed by Kubernetes, or GKE.
Then I have my choice of load balancers.
I can use familiar tools like Envoy or Nginx.
And then I can use things like OpenCensus
to add some visibility to my application
and visualize all that in Stackdriver Trace.
And then I can move on to try new ideas,
like adding voice integration
to my application,
all within the Google Cloud Platform.
And with that, I'd like to introduce
our next speaker, Aja,
who's going to come out
and talk more about languages.
Thank you.
(cheers and applause)
♪ (music) ♪
Hi, I'm Aja,
and I lead our programming languages efforts
on the Google Cloud Developer Advocacy team.
I like working
in developer relations at Google
because this job lets engineers, like myself,
spend our time helping people
build cool things
and giving back to our tech communities.
My community has given me
a lot over the years,
and I'm really grateful
that I get this chance to give back.
And I work on languages because
I'm kind of a giant language nerd.
I'd love to talk to you about
all the languages I enjoy using,
but they only gave me time to talk to you
about two of them today.
So the first language
we're going to talk about is Go.
Go is growing so much right now.
There are an estimated
one million gophers worldwide.
But, more practically,
when I go to my local DevOps meetup,
Go is the language we talk about the most.
Folks are using it for lots of stuff,
like building microservices
and improving their operations.
And so I'm like,
"Hey, guys, what's with the Go?"
And they give me lots
of reasons they like it.
First off, it's the language
of the containers world.
Almost everything Kelsey just showed
was written in Go,
including Docker and Kubernetes.
And Go is great for systems-level programming
because it's fast, and it was built
from the ground up
with concurrency support.
For those coming from languages
where concurrency
was kind of tacked on later,
having concurrency as a first-class concept
is really delightful.
And folks also like that Go
is developer-friendly.
There are very few keywords,
and it uses familiar syntax.
And gophers rave about
how easy it is to write,
how it has the speed of a compiled language
and all the benefits of static typing.
And all of that leads to faster performance,
reduced QA time,
and fewer errors in production.
Personally, my favorite thing about Go
is the welcoming and supportive community
of passionate gophers throughout the world.
So, today I want to talk about the new
Go Cloud Project from Google.
This library provides gophers
with cloud-agnostic abstractions
for services like relational data stores,
runtime configs and blob storage.
So that's a bunch of words,
but let's say you have an application
that uses Google Cloud Storage
and storage on some other provider.
Currently you have to have
two branches in your code,
one for each provider.
You have to remember that maybe one provider
uses the method ListBucketContents
to see what's in a bucket
and the other uses something,
I don't know, maybe describe-bucket
and it's doing the same thing
but I don't want to keep all that in my head.
I'm lazy.
And the Go Cloud Project helps with this
by providing one set of objects and methods
that work with multiple cloud providers.
You don't have to learn an API
for each provider.
You can use one method
and the Go Cloud Project
takes care of translating it
to the right method for that cloud,
or maybe even multiple methods.
And the return data
is consistent between clouds,
so you don't have to worry about doing
all sorts of cloud-specific type checking.
The big thing, though,
is that with the Go Cloud Project
your application code
doesn't need to be aware
of what back end you're using,
or even if you're using multiple clouds.
The API it provides allows you
to set up your application code
from the configuration needed
to connect to the cloud
so you can focus on the fun stuff,
like adding new features.
Ino, from the Advocacy team,
is with us today,
and he's going to demonstrate
the Go Cloud Project.
(cheers and applause)
So, Ino has an application
that uploads a photo to cloud storage
on either GCP or AWS.
And, of course, we're going
to upload a picture of a gopher.
So, here's the application code
that runs that.
And you can see that in each method
we have a top-level conditional
for choosing between
the two clouds we have to support.
And under each branch the code is similar,
but it's not entirely the same.
Each cloud is initialized
a little differently
and it provides objects
with different methods
for handling the results
you get back from storage.
And I've written code like this,
but I'm not particularly proud of it,
because it's really gross.
And here's the thing.
We can do a lot better.
So here's a version of the code
that uses the Go Cloud Project.
The first thing you're going to see
is that that top-level conditional is gone.
What we've done is we've separated
the application logic
from the storage configuration.
And to make it really clear,
here's the diff between the two versions.
Adam promised you all a diff.
Here's the diff.
You can see that there's a lot less code
in the version that uses
the Go Cloud library.
And, even better,
the code that uses the library
has a better design, because
we've separated the two concerns.
Better engineering practices
lead to more maintainable code.
Thank you, Ino!
(applause)
If you've ever had to support multiple clouds
in a single application,
you know that using a library
like the Go Cloud Project
is a much easier way to do things,
and it encourages good engineering practice.
But library authors can also build
on top of the Go Cloud Project
to ensure that folks on any provider
can use their library.
Our hope is that this project will foster
an ecosystem of libraries
built with multi-cloud portability in mind.
The Go Cloud Project is,
of course, open source,
currently supports AWS and GCP,
but more clouds are coming soon.
And, of course, contributions welcome.
So, the second language I want
to talk about today is JavaScript.
JavaScript was the most popular language
on GitHub last year.
There were so many more JavaScript commits
as there were for any other language--
it's really remarkable.
And I know I've written a bunch
of JavaScript in my career
and I'm assuming most of you have as well.
Google has been a champion
of the JavaScript language
for a really long time.
Some of Google's JavaScript projects
include Angular, AMP, Polymer,
and the V8 engine
that's at the heart of Node.js.
And JavaScript is one
of those fantastic languages
that you can use just about anywhere
for just about anything.
If you'd told me in 1995
that I would be writing
server-side JavaScript
I wouldn't have believed you.
But the async features
of something like Node.js
help you build fast, scaleable
web application back ends,
and Node.js is also the default language
for Functions as a Service.
But it can be used for non-web
applications too, like robotics.
And, of course, JavaScript
is as popular as ever
for building rich client-side
interactive experiences.
So, if you go out and learn JavaScript
there really isn't much you can't do.
The community has been asking
for Node.js on App Engine standard,
and we're happy to say that it's in beta.
Node 8 can be used just like
your other App Engine language
and you can use most
of your favorite MPM modules.
And if you don't know,
App Engine is GCP's
Platform as a Service product.
It's been around for a long time--
we just celebrated the 10th anniversary--
and all of the fans of App Engine
like the ease of use,
autoscaling, security,
and how well it integrates
with all the other GCP products,
like Datastore.
And with this, Node.js now runs
on every single compute platform
the GCP offers.
I told you you could do anything with Node!
So, it's really important to me,
and all of my friends over there
dressed in red
on the Cloud Developer Relations team,
(cheers and applause)
that Google is an active participant
and a good citizen
in our developer communities.
After all, the best tools
are written by developers
who understand a community's
needs and idiosyncrasies.
And we like to put our code
where our mouth is.
And we do that by contributing
to improving the languages
and surrounding ecosystems.
So that's why Google Cloud
is a Platinum Sponsor
of the Node Foundation,
and it's also why there are many googlers
participating in Node,
in a variety of roles--
giving their time and expertise
to help guide the future of the language.
They only gave me
a couple of minutes today,
so I was only able to talk about a few
of the popular languages.
And even then, I only focused
on their server-side uses.
But client and mobile development
are important and growing too.
So next you're going to hear
from Sam and Francis,
and they're going to talk
about Firebase development
and development
with GCP products for mobile.
♪ (music) ♪
Thanks, Aja.
Our mission for Firebase is
to help mobile app teams succeed
by providing you a platform
to help solve the key problems
across the lifecycle of your app--
from building your app,
to improving your app quality,
to growing your business.
We've come a long way since two years ago,
when we expanded Firebase
from a real-time database
to a broad app-development platform.
And it's so exciting to see
there are now over 1.2 million apps
actively using Firebase every month,
including many of the top
Android and iOS apps
like The New York TImes, Box, and Pandora.
Now as you've heard earlier,
Google Cloud offers
a wide variety of products
to help you build secure
and scaleable infrastructure.
So when it comes time to build
your mobile app for your business,
Firebase integrates smoothly with GCP
to help you build it better and faster.
To show you how easy it is
to build an app with Firebase,
I'd like to welcome
one of my teammates, Sam, to join us.
(cheers and applause)
(Sam) Hello. Thank you, Francis.
So, one of the first problems
that most mobile app developers face
is finding a way to store and sync
their data in the cloud,
ideally without managing any infrastructure.
Cloud Firestore was built
to solve this problem
on every platform that you work on.
It's a fully managed noSQL database
built on Google's global infrastructure.
Now, let's say I'm the developer
of a financial services app
called NextWallet.
My users have been asking me for a long time
to add a mobile app
to complement the web app.
Firebase helps you build apps
on Android, iOS, and the web,
but today I'm just going to focus
on building an Android app.
So here we are in the Firebase console.
And you can see I've already got
all my data in Cloud Firestore.
This is a list of my recent transactions.
I went to Sam's Place, and I spent about $45.
Moving over to Android Studio,
I want to load all of my transactions here.
I want to display
the user's recent transactions.
So let's do that.
Here...
... Okay, so what I'm doing here
is I'm getting the ID
of the currently signed-in user.
And then you can see here I'm forming a query
using the Firestore Android SDK.
We're asking for the user's
latest 50 transactions,
ordered by time.
You'll also notice I can query this data
directly from my app,
without building any API servers or proxies.
I'm accessing the remote data
as if it was in a local database.
So, if I run this in the emulator,
you can see that all of the transactions
from the console
are now displayed in the app.
And this connection is completely
real-time by default.
So if I go to the console
and change the name of one of the places--
change Sam's Place to Sam's Awesome Place,
it updated in the app
before we could even switch screens.
So with barely any code,
my mobile app is showing
the same data as my web app,
in real time.
Now, if you're used to accessing
a database via a REST API,
you may have found it strange
I did not include any tokens
or headers in my request.
That's because Cloud Firestore
automatically detects
that I'm signed in
with Firebase authentication
and includes that auth state transparently.
So every request from my app
to Cloud Firestore
is checked by Firebase rules,
which is a declarative system
for controlling access to Firebase resources.
So let's see the rules
that are keeping this app safe.
So these are my custom security rules.
Here, I'm making sure that users
can only read and write their own data.
And here I've locked down rights
to transactional information
to prevent any sort of spoofing.
It's really powerful to have
direct client access to your data
without running any authentication servers
or API proxies.
It completely streamlines
your development process.
And, even more importantly,
it reduces the surface for bugs
or for vulnerabilities.
Now, with sensitive applications
like this finance app,
you can't do everything on the client side.
If I need to add some critical business logic
I want to run it in a trusted location.
So the newest feature in my app
is that users can pay their bills.
And, unlike viewing recent transactions,
this is a really privileged operation.
So, moving here, I'll write
a serverless Node.js function
to pay a bill from the user's bank account
and then mark it as paid,
and I'll deploy this whole thing
to Cloud Functions.
You can see here that I've got a function.
It's called payBill.
And after the bill is paid it marks
the paid state to true
in Firestore.
Now, in the Android app
we can simply call this function
by its name, payBill,
the same name I defined,
and we can pass in the ID
of the bill we want to pay.
After the function runs,
I'll get this callback here with the result.
Just like with the data call
to Cloud Firestore,
our authentication state is passed
seamlessly in the request,
so users can only access their own bills.
So now let's use it.
Let's pay a bill.
Hit this here, and what just happened
was the Cloud Function ran
and made the update,
which was detected
by the client in real time.
So in just the last few minutes
we set up a secure, scaleable
and real-time connection to our data,
and also deployed a Cloud Function
to perform trusted actions,
which is pretty impressive, right?
(cheers and applause)
(Francis) Once your app is built,
you'll likely be looking to improve
your app's stability and performance,
since the first impression the app makes
is crucial to the long-term success
of your business.
Now, we've seen through Google Play
that 42% of one-star reviews
mentioned instability or bugs,
whereas 73% of five-star reviews
mentioned design,
usability, or speed.
So having a stable and speedy app
is essential to your success.
So let's switch it back over to Sam
to take a look at some of the ways
that Firebase helps you
improve your app quality.
So as a mobile developer
I have to release my code into the wild,
and it could end up
on any kind of device or any network.
I need to know how it's performing,
and, more importantly,
I need to know when it's crashing.
If I wait to hear about crashes
in bad Play Store reviews,
that's way too late.
So all I have to do
to track crashes in this app
is add this single-line dependency
on Crashlytics.
I don't have to write a line
of real Android code.
Now, let's go into the Firebase console
and see what crashes
are happening for my users.
So here I can see that I had a crash,
but I don't know why yet.
Let's take a look at the trace.
I can see that it was a fatal exception.
I can see the exact line where it occurred.
I can also see some information
about the device,
where it happened, and the environment.
Through an integration with Slack
I can get new crashes like this
sent to me and my team in real time.
Now, here in the Logs panel,
I can see we have a list of analytics events
that preceded the crash.
Event logging from Google Analytics
to Crashlytics is automatic
and it provides really helpful context.
So now I have a ton of information
on what the user is doing to cause the crash,
which allows me to debug my app
more efficiently.
I can spend more of my time
and my team's resources
on building features for my users.
And now that we can measure
if the app is stable,
I still need to directly measure
the goals of my business.
So for the new Bill Pay feature
I want to make sure
that users are able
to find the tab in the app,
pay the bill,
and that it all runs successfully.
Firebase provides free
unlimited mobile analytics
and automatically measures
common events in your app.
But I want to add custom analytics
for each Bill Pay event
for the attempt, success, and the failure
so I can track user behavior here.
So if we move back into Android Studio,
in the Bill Pay flow I'll add calls
around the common parts of the flow.
So here I'll log the attempt.
Here I'll log when it succeeds.
And here I'll log when it fails.
You can see that for each event
I just pick a name
and then I pass a bundle of parameters.
Now that the code's running,
if I go back into the app and pay a bill,
those events will fire.
Heading back into the console,
I can see these events
coming in, in real time.
By defining custom events,
you can measure the things
that uniquely matter to your business.
Analytics is the backbone of Firebase
and the foundation for a successful business.
(Francis) Having the right analytics
is the first step to ensure
your users are happy
and your app is doing the job
you want it to do.
But once you have the data,
you'll want to put it to work
for your business.
With Firebase, you can export
your analytics data into BigQuery,
join it with other data sources,
and perform deeper analysis.
You can also take action right directly
from the Firebase console,
and it comes with a built-in
A/B testing framework.
So, for example,
you can send push notifications
or test different configurations of your app
without having to redeploy
to the app store or Google Play.
With A/B testing,
you can define different variants,
set the primary and secondary goals
for your experiments,
and the system will automatically
do the hard work for you
to help you find the optimal variant.
And once you have the winner,
you can roll that experience out
to the rest of your user base
without another app deployment.
Firebase also helps you take targeted action
by leveraging machine learning.
Now, it's one thing to take action
based on past user behavior,
but with Firebase Predictions
you can apply ML to your analytics data
to take targeted actions
based on predicted future behavior.
So, for example, you can send special offers
to users who are likely to leave your app.
Or, in Sam's example,
he can send push notifications
targeted to users who are likely
to miss a bill payment.
So Predictions was
the first step that we took
to bring the power
of Google's ML to work for you.
Two months ago we took our second step,
with the release of ML Kit in public beta.
With ML Kit we're bringing together
machine learning technologies
from across Google,
and making that available
to every mobile developer
working on Android and iOS.
ML Kit comes with five APIs out of the box,
like image labeling and text recognition,
and you can run these APIs on-device
for low-latency processing
or in the cloud
for higher levels of accuracy.
And if you have more sophisticated needs,
you can upload your own
custom TensorFlow Lite model
and serve that through Google's
global infrastructure.
Your app can dynamically
retrieve these models
and evaluate them on-device,
so that means you don't need
to bundle the model with your app binary
and you can update it
without pushing an app updates.
And since ML Kit is available
through Firebase,
it makes it easy for you to take advantage
of the broader Firebase platform.
For example, experimenting
with different custom models
using A/B testing,
or storing your image label
into Cloud Firestore,
or understanding the impact
on user engagement
with Google Analytics.
We are so excited about the possibilities
that machine learning unlocks.
Whether it's to supercharge your growth
or build amazing user experiences,
we want to harness Google's advances
to help you you build and grow your apps.
And with that, I'd like
to hand it over to Yufeng,
to talk more about Cloud AI.
Thank you.
(applause)
♪ (music) ♪
Thank you, Francis.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Yufeng Guo,
and I'm a Developer Advocate
here at Google Cloud.
Over the past four years
that I've been at Google
machine learning has taken on
a greater and greater prominence
in both our internal usage
as well as in our external offerings.
Today I want to provide you
with a user's guide
to thinking about machine learning problems.
We'll talk about how to find
the right tools for your task
depending on your needs,
and we'll discuss four groups
of tools and workflows
that can be used to drive insights
to build your applications:
machine learning APIs, data processing,
model-building, and scaling up.
Let's start with APIs.
Say you have some video or sound data
that you want to annotate
with labels and transcripts.
Historically, this would have been
a challenging and manual task.
Video Intelligence API allows you
to turn a video
into a set of labels and scenes
to build understanding,
while the Speech API
can turn sound into text.
This means you can now focus
on doing something useful
with your newly tagged audio and video files
instead of getting stuck
on how to label and transcribe it all.
Additionally, there is the Video API,
the Natural Language API,
and the Translate API,
which handle images, text,
in the many languages of the world,
enabling you to easily transform
and augment your existing data.
Together, you can think of these five APIs
as simple building blocks
for your application.
They're literally just REST APIs
that you can call and get JSON back.
Now, if these pre-trained APIs
don't give quite enough detail for you,
you can customize them
to produce state-of-the-art models,
using AutoML for vision,
natural language, and translation.
All you need to do is provide the data
for your specific use case,
and AutoML will train up
a custom API endpoint
just for your particular interest.
So that's the story
of the machine learning APIs--
easy to use, and simple to customize.
But what about other forms of data?
Let's say you've got
a data scientist at your company,
or perhaps you are
the data scientist at your company,
and this data scientist,
she is chomping at the bit
to get her hands on
as many datasets as possible
to find interesting relationships
that might exist.
But, alas, your data is big and it's messy.
It's stored in a variety
of formats and places.
How can we use machine learning
to get some meaningful outcomes
out of this, well, pile of data?
First, I want to clarify
that machine learning is not magic,
but, rather, it essentially boils down
to using many examples to make predictions,
or at least try to make predictions.
And so a large part of the work
is around getting the data organized.
And because data is often stored
in a variety of places,
for good reason I'm sure,
gathering it together, where possible,
is a good first step,
before then trying to see and get a sense
of just what it is you're dealing with.
And how might you do that on GCP?
Perhaps you explore it in BigQuery,
run some preprocessing
on Dataflow or Dataproc,
and take a peek at the results
in a Jupyter notebook.
Or perhaps you run the data through Dataprep
and output the results to Cloud Storage
and save some metadata to Cloud SQL.
However you approach it,
careful management
of your data is the key factor
in being able to do
any kind of meaningful analysis
and, of course, machine learning.
So be a good steward to your data,
and it will reward you.
Okay, so let's say we've got all our data
set up and ready to go.
It's been turned inside out, upside down,
and arranged just right.
What's the next step
in our data scientist's journey?
It's time for her to make some models.
If she's already got a dataset
stored in BigQuery,
thanks to all that work
in getting the data prepared,
it may be worth running some,
say, linear regressions
directly in SQL, using BigQuery ML.
And, for a more sophisticated approach,
she can look to TensorFlow,
Google's popular
open source deep learning library.
It's flexible and extensible,
but, best of all,
runs on all manner of platforms,
from CPUs and GPUs as well as mobile and web.
Initially, she'll most likely run TensorFlow
on her local environment,
say in a Jupyter notebook.
Maybe she samples a subset
of the larger dataset from the cloud
and builds a few different models
to try out different ideas she has.
Running TensorFlow models
against a subset of the data
is all well and good,
but then when it comes time
to train some models
on the full real dataset,
running everything on her local laptop
is probably not so realistic.
Just getting the data downloaded
would take a while.
So if we can't bring the data
down to the models,
let's bring the models to the data,
by running machine learning in the cloud.
Imagine being able
to train a model in the cloud
by just sending up your TensorFlow code
and virtually nothing else.
That's basically what training a model
on Cloud ML Engine is like.
You can train a TensorFlow model, at scale,
without needing to configure machines
or install libraries.
You just don't have
to fiddle with that stuff.
Now this has three
very important implications.
First, it means you can kick off
multiple training jobs in parallel
allowing you to try out different approaches
with different datasets.
And then, well, you can just go get a coffee.
Second, Cloud ML Engine features
a hyperparameter tuning service
that runs in parallel
and uses Bayesian optimization
to try different variants of the same model
and find the one
that has the best performance.
And, third, running TensorFlow Training
on Cloud ML Engine
gives you access not only to CPUs
and a whole lot of GPUs,
but also TPUs,
Google's custom accelerator chip
built for deep learning.
Now once your model is done training,
it's time to serve predictions.
And, as most of you know,
standing up a production server
is no easy feat.
But with Cloud ML Engine
there are just three steps.
Are you ready?
Step one--Provide a name
for this version of your model.
It can be whatever you want.
Let's call ours version_awesome
Step two--Provide a location
where the exported model file lives.
And Step three--Click Save.
Okay, so we did our three steps.
What did that get us?
We've actually already got ourselves
an autoscaling REST API
that can be called
from any internet-connected device
on the planet.
And if you thought that's neat,
wait until you find out you can also
run your existing models
that are using, say, Scikit-learn and XGBoost
on Cloud ML Engine as well.
So you can have just one workflow
to train and deploy models to the cloud,
regardless of whether it's using
traditional approaches
or deep learning approaches.
Machine learning, it's not easy.
But when you take our suite
of cloud-native, serverless tools
to ingest, transform, and manage your data,
and then combine it
with TensorFlow and Cloud ML Engine,
you'll be well equipped
to journey into the next generation
of intelligent applications.
And if you're ready to dive deeper
into machine learning and data science,
check out Cloud AI Adventures on YouTube,
which explores the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
You can catch it at YouTube/AI Adventures.
But I know videos aren't for everyone,
so here to tell you more about
where you can find a community of learners
who are supporting each other
to grow in their skills
and share in their knowledge
is Anthony Goldbloom, CEO of Kaggle.
(applause)
♪ (music) ♪
So thanks, Yufeng.
I'm Anthony Goldbloom, CEO of Kaggle.
And it's really nice
to be back on the Next stage.
It was actually on this stage last year
that we announced
that Kaggle was joining Google.
So for those of you who don't know Kaggle,
we are the world's largest
machine learning community.
We're going to pass 2 million members
in the next couple of weeks.
Now, at the beginning of the show
Adam asked how many of you
had deployed a machine learning model
and it seems like not very many.
We want to change that.
We want to be a part
of your entire machine learning journey.
Our community ranges
from people just learning Python
through to the researchers
behind deep neural networks.
Kaggle rankings are probably
the most widely recognized
machine learning credential at this point
and so we've seen many in our community
going from being total newbies
to having elite AI roles.
So the Kaggle community started out
with machine learning competitions,
so a lot of you will think of Kaggle
as machine learning competitions,
but we've expanded well beyond that.
If you're a software engineer
you go to Stack Overflow
for your question answering
and you go to GitHub for code collaboration.
What Kaggle's trying to do
is be the one place you go for your...
... As a member
of the machine learning community,
we're giving you
the one destination you need to go.
So in addition to competitions,
we offer several other things.
We offer Kaggle Learn,
which is short-form AI education.
We offer Kaggle Kernels,
which is a cloud-based workbench
for data science and machine learning.
And we have a Datasets platform
where we have almost 10,000 datasets
that have been shared among our community.
And so I'm going to give you a tour
of each of these parts of Kaggle,
and help to show you how they fit
into your machine learning journey.
So if you're brand new
to AI and machine learning
I suggest starting with Kaggle Learn.
As I mentioned, this is
very short-form AI education.
So if you go to Udacity,
the main machine learning course
takes six months.
Kaggle Learn has you training your first
deep neural network in 30 minutes.
Now, we're not teaching you
everything there is to know
about deep neural networks in 30 minutes,
but what we are doing is
we're giving you enough of a basis
to get going on your own projects.
So we have a cloud-based environment
called Kaggle Kernels,
and you can use it with Kaggle Learn,
but actually you can use it
for most machine learning projects now.
Kaggle Kernels allows you to avoid the pain
of setting up your own environment.
So we give you a cloud-based environment
in the browser,
that will give you machine learning
with most of the major packages
that you could want.
We are strong believers
that the future of data science
and machine learning
is going to be done in the cloud,
in an environment like Kaggle Kernels--
hopefully Kaggle Kernels, for you.
And the reason being is
that machine learning workloads
are very bursty.
One minute you're exploring your data,
the next minute you're training
a very large deep neural network.
So the cloud is perfect for such workloads.
So with Kaggle Kernels you choose
between a Jupyter notebook interface
or a normal IDE.
You choose between Python and R,
so those are the two main
data science machine learning languages.
And by default we give you a CPU,
but you can also have access to a GPU
if you want more compute.
You can see your datasets
and see previews of your dataset,
and the code executes
on Google Cloud servers.
So you get six hours of compute
per session at no cost.
So actually this will cover the majority
of your machine learning workloads.
Okay. So through Kaggle Learn
you've learned an algorithm.
Through Kaggle Kernels
you have an environment set up.
Now you're ready
to start working on a project,
and we have two projects at Kaggle
that you can work on.
We have Kaggle Competitions
and we have our Datasets platform.
Now the way competitions work
is a company will post a problem,
and data scientists
and machine learners compete
to build the best algorithm on that problem.
So, at any point in time,
we're running 10-15 competitions.
Right now, if you come to the site,
you'll see we're working with Zillow
to improve the Zestimate
Home Valuation algorithm.
And we're also working with CERN
to build an algorithm
that better detects particle collisions
in the Large Hadron Collider.
I like showing those two use cases
because they give you a sense of the breadth
of machine learning and how it's applica...
Those are totally different use cases, right?
And it's applicable to both.
Now, during the competition--
you can see on the second cube--
you can see a live leaderboard
which shows you how you're performing
relative to others.
So it also shows you,
if you're not in first place,
it shows you how much better
it's possible to do.
So if you're scoring 50%,
and somebody else is scoring 90%,
they're found something
that you haven't found.
Very rewarding, also,
while you're participating
in the competitions we have forums,
where people are sharing
techniques and ideas.
and so you never run out
of ideas of things to try.
All you need to do is read the forums
if you're running out of ideas.
And, actually, at the end of the competition
very often what we'll see
is we'll see the top performers will share
the results of their model in the forums.
Sorry, the approach they took.
So you kind of get to learn
what the right answer is.
Alright.
So our Datasets platform is the other place
you can go and do projects,
and this is really good
for more freeform projects.
Our community has shared
almost 10,000 datasets at this point.
So even if you have your own dataset
that you want to work on,
rather than working in isolation
on your local machine,
why not bring it to Kaggle?
And then others who are also
interested in that dataset
will work on it with you, right?
You'll attract a small community of people
who are interested
in the problem you're working on.
On the flip side,
if you don't have a dataset
that you're itching to work with,
as I said, we have almost 10,000 datasets.
And the range of topics
is kind of breathtaking.
I'll show you in a minute.
But there is almost certainly
a dataset that meets your interests.
So I'm going to show you what it looks like
to work on our Datasets platform.
Here I'm browsing the datasets
that others have uploaded,
and I'll find a dataset on avocado prices.
I like avocado toast,
so I figure I'll jump into this one.
And rather than starting from scratch,
I start looking at what others
have done on this dataset.
And I notice that somebody
called Samuel Belko
has already written a forecasting model.
And his forecasting model has done
exactly the kinds of things
that I would want to do.
I'm scrolling quickly, but you can see
he's done some exploration,
he's doing some charting,
then he uses quite a well-known
time series forecasting package
in order to make a prediction.
So I hit the Fork button,
and that gives me...
When I hit Fork, what's happening
behind the scenes is I'm forking the code,
the Docker container,
and the connection to the data.
So I get his code, in an environment
that will run it immediately.
And, as you can see, I'm scrolling through,
I have exactly the same code that he has.
And then when I start executing the cells,
I'm getting the same results that he gets.
So, as I dig into his results,
I notice that avocado prices
rose pretty dramatically in 2017,
and I want to build a model
that sort of fits that period nicely,
and explains that period nicely.
So I go in, and I add a dataset,
and I add a dataset with Starbucks locations,
which at first glance sounds kind of odd.
What do avocado prices
and Starbucks locations
have to do with each other?
Well, it turns out that Starbucks
rolled out an avocado spread,
nationwide, in 2017,
and so when I add in the dataset
on Starbucks locations
it helps me to evaluate the impact
of the additional Starbucks' demand
on avocado prices.
So you can see how I can go
and extend Samuel's model
by adding in an extra dataset,
and adding that dataset into the model.
If I wanted to grab weather data, as well--
almost certainly we have a weather dataset
for some of the main avocado-growing regions.
So maybe that had an impact on supply.
So hopefully that gives you a sense
for how many learning opportunities,
how many interesting datasets,
how much there is to do
on the Kaggle Datasets platform.
So, as I said at the beginning,
Kaggle wants to be a part
of your whole machine learning journey.
And so over the coming year,
you'll start to see us add in
more commercial-grade features.
You'll start to see us allow you
to connect your Kaggle accounts
to your GCP accounts.
You'll be able to access
the datasets you have in BigQuery.
You'll be able to deploy your models
to Cloud ML Engine.
And so you'll get the content
that has been shared
with the Kaggle community,
plus the power of GCP's data analytics
and machine learning services.
So for those of you who haven't yet deployed
your first machine learning model,
who aren't yet a part of our community,
we'd love you to sign up.
We want to help accelerate
your machine learning journey.
So Kaggle is one of the great communities
around GCP,
but next on stage we have Sam O'Keefe,
who heads up Google Cloud for Startups.
And Sam is going to talk about
some of the other communities
we have around GCP.
Thank you.
(applause)
♪ (music) ♪
Thanks, Anthony.
Kaggle and GCP's machine learning tools
are just a few examples
of the way that Google's values manifest
in the tools and technology we create.
I hope you're heard by now, but just in case,
we are committed to openness,
and we want all of you,
the community, involved.
Next up, we'll hear
from one of our close partners,
who shares those values--
Unity Technologies.
We recently announced that GCP
would be powering the Unity platform.
With this seamless integration,
game developers get to focus
on what they love--
being creative and building
immersive experiences for their users,
while we take care of the infrastructure.
Let's take a peek.
♪ (music) ♪
(applause)
Here to tell us more,
please welcome Suhail Dutta,
VP of Cloud Services for Unity.
♪ (music) ♪
At Unity, we believe
the world's a better place
with more creators in it.
So whether we're helping Steven Spielberg
shoot Ready Player One
on a virtual set;
or working with NASA
on visualizing the Mars Rover;
empowering Lexus to design
and market the LC500,
or providing Ludia with the tools
to create Jurassic World Alive,
Unity is the most widely used,
real-time, 3D development platform.
And we're empowering millions of creators
to achieve their aspirations.
At Unity, we live by three principles:
democratize development,
solve hard problems,
enable success.
One of the hardest problems in gaming
is building what we call connected games.
So games that help their players connect
and play with each other
are easily the most
influential games out there.
They're the most played, the most watched,
and the most successful.
In fact, 90% of the top grossing apps
on Google Play
are connected games.
But creating them is hard.
Building an experience
that delights your users
all across the world
requires a lot of infrastructure--
the time and expertise to manage it,
and 24/7 support.
At Unity, we want to change that.
And so does Google.
Last month, we announced a strategic alliance
to help simplify the development
of connected games.
And we're doing this
keeping two tenets in mind:
scaleable and approachable.
Scaleable, so you can create your game
the right way from day one,
whether you have one player or a million.
And we do this with efficient,
high-performance networking
and enterprise-grade server hosting.
We also use our tools and services
to provide a seamless integration
between Unity and Google Cloud,
so you can get started quickly
and focus on what you do best--
creating great experiences.
Our first collaboration,
a service that helps match players into games
based on an open source
matchmaking project,
is coming out later this summer.
It's called Open Match.
Not only do we believe
that Google Cloud
is the right cloud for our customers,
but we're also migrating our infrastructure
over to Google Cloud.
Together, we're making it easier
for you to build and operate
your connected experiences.
We can't wait to see what you create.
Thank you.
(applause)
Unity's developer community
continues to demonstrate
that with the right tools,
small teams can build products
that reach and are enjoyed by millions.
I have the unique opportunity
to witness this every day
as part of Google Cloud for Startups.
At Google Cloud for Startups,
we help developers from all over the world
get their businesses up and running on GCP.
We do this by providing access--
access to content, to help you learn;
and technical mentors,
for when you get stuck;
access to Google products
at a discounted rate,
so they're affordable
when you're in your garage phase;
and, most importantly,
access to a community,
a community of peers facing and solving
the same technical
and non-technical challenges that you are.
In keeping with our theme of openness,
Google Cloud for Startups
truly is for everyone--
from two developers
working on their first MVP,
to a team that just found
product/market fit and is figuring out,
"How the heck are we going
to keep this thing going?"--
Google wants to be there.
You can get started today
by going to our website,
and we'd love to meet you.
In the past year, thousands of startups
have made the decision
to build with Google.
You saw a few of these startups
in the video earlier,
but they're really doing everything--
they're leveraging machine learning
to structure healthcare data;
using IoT devices
to create factories of the future;
and, if you're here in the Bay Area,
they're putting everything on the blockchain.
Today I'm excited to have two startups here,
to share their story,
and show us all what's possible
with Google Cloud.
As we heard in Aja's talk earlier,
JavaScript is one
of the most popular languages today.
So our first startup
might be familiar to many of you.
npm provides the largest
software registry in the world,
enabling over 11 million JS developers
to build web applications.
Please join me in welcoming
CTO, CJ Silverio,
as she tells us how a team
of three engineers gets it done.
♪ (music) ♪
How many of you here work
for a company that has a website?
Website? Anyone?
Yeah, your company has a website? Great.
You are my user.
Hi, I'm CJ Silverio, CTO of npm, Inc.
Now, npm powers the world's largest registry
of open source software.
If you have a website,
use any modern front-end framework,
your developers type npm install.
You use us because we are
how the world shares JavaScript.
I'm here today because our team
took our global registry
and created an enterprise-ready version of it
to help developers at big companies
use open source code at work.
We did using Google Kubernetes Engine.
npm's registry
is a complex distributed system.
It stores data in three different databases
and a Cloud Object store,
and it has the usual thicket of microservices
shuttling that data around.
It was designed to make it easy
for us to scale the registry
to a billion downloads a day,
supporting our 11 million users, all of you.
It's massive, and it's reliable,
to the point that people don't even
think about what happens
when they type npm install.
Here's the twist.
We had enterprise companies asking us
how they could have
their own private npm registry--
all the features of the public registry,
but meeting their greater need
for control over their source code.
The challenge was to take
a super redundant architecture
that sprawls across hundreds
of cloud instances,
and package it into something
easy to install, manage, and operate.
Now that's a lot of complexity
that has to be reduced
and delivered to a single customer.
Did I mention that npm is a small company?
Because we are.
And we already have a full-time job
running the world's largest registry
of open source software.
Containerization was clearly
the way for us to go with this,
and for the first version of this product,
we containerized.
But we did that with a hand-tuned,
single-size container deployment.
And we ended up with something
that was hard to scale and hard to update.
When we looked at doing another take on it,
we knew we had to use Kubernetes.
Now, just saying, "Yeah, Kubernetes,"
is not an answer.
You have to install Kubernetes,
you have to manage it,
and you have to operate it.
And then you have to scale that to demand
as we bring in new customers,
and as our customers grow
and add users and packages.
So the idea of building
all this infrastructure ourselves
was daunting.
Google Kubernetes Engine, though,
had exactly the API we needed.
It may sound like a line
fed to me by marketing,
but it's literally true.
Give me a cluster.
Here are my compute memory requirements.
Go!
GKE gives me a cluster.
Now I need a place
to store my customers' data
and keep it backed up.
Google Cloud Storage is right there.
Now, I need isolation,
so I can manage and bill
each of our customers separately.
We use GCP's Projects
within our Google Cloud organization,
to keep our customers' resources isolated.
So, no joke, a few months later,
a single team of three developers
built and shipped an all new npm Enterprise,
and it's serving customers now.
You can run the exact software
that the npm registry runs,
with your own authentication,
in a single-tenant environment,
all on Google Cloud.
We can provision a cluster, scale it,
keep our customers upgraded,
and I didn't need to hire a staff
that's expert in Kubernetes, to do it.
Enterprise customers get all the features
the public registry gets
at the same time it gets them.
Using GKE shaved a year
off of our development time
and let us focus on what we do best--
building amazing software.
npm's mission is to reduce developer friction
for every single
software developer in the world.
GKE reduced friction for us,
so that we can deliver
this amazing thing to you,
so that you can build
amazing things yourselves.
Sam, we're big fans of GKE,
and I'm super excited for what's ahead.
(Sam) I am, too.
And congratulations on everything
you've accomplished so far.
Thank you, CJ.
(applause)
I don't think it'll be a surprise
to anyone in this audience
when I say that data
is critical to machine learning.
Much like how Google's Fei-Fei Li
created ImageNet
sparked a frenzy of advancement in the field,
our next startup is building
a massive dataset of their own.
This time, that dataset consists
of millions of microscopic images
of human cells.
Armed with this data, and Google Cloud,
Recursion Pharmaceuticals is on a mission
to redefine the drug discovery process
and bring life-saving drugs to market faster.
Please join me in welcoming Lina Nilsson,
Senior Director of Data Science
at Recursion Pharmaceuticals,
to tell us more.
♪ (music) ♪
We are decoding biology
in order to find new medical treatments.
I'm Lina Nilsson, and I am
incredibly excited to be here today
to share with you Recursion's vision
for the future of drug discovery.
The number of new drugs
approved each year by the FDA
has been essentially stagnant
since the 1980s,
and the development cost
of each of those few drugs
has increased tenfold,
to well over two billion dollars.
Contrast this to the world of tech,
where costs are coming down all the time,
and where the smartphone
in my pocket has more compute
than a 1980s supercomputer.
So why has drug discovery not
followed this same pattern?
The traditional scientific workflow
is sequential.
Researchers work on one disease
and one hypothesis at a time.
This works, but the rate
of finding new treatments is slow.
At Recursion, we're transforming
this old process
into a new formula, where we test dozens,
or even hundreds of diseases at once.
And instead of testing
one hypothesis at a time
across that dataset,
we're able to be open
to millions of possible outcomes,
in an unbiased way.
And this new formula gives us the ability
to dramatically speed up
the discovery of new drugs.
The key to all of this is a combination of:
one, large-scale biology
on our automated robotics platform,
then two, prediction
and inference on the cloud,
and, finally, rigorous
biology validation in the lab
to complete the drug discovery process.
So let's dig in a bit,
and I'll show you a bit more
about how this all works.
The first step is automated robotics.
Recursion has built an automated lab,
full of robots, that run about
100,000 experiments every week.
This gives us two million biology images
to work with every week.
By the end of this year,
we'll have the capability to generate
nearly 1 PB of image data every month.
This dwarfs ImageNet.
And these biology images
are then streamed to Google Cloud
and are run through
our data processing platform,
which leverages Google Kubernetes Engine,
BigQuery, and, of course,
Google Cloud Storage.
And this is what those microscope images
of human cells look like.
Each image you see
shows a different cell type,
exposed to different diseases,
and, of course,
different potential treatments.
But generating millions of images alone,
that's not really going to help us
reach our ambitious goal.
It is only transformative when we layer on
machine learning analytics on the cloud
in order to discover
important patterns in the data.
Using preemptable virtual machines,
for example,
our workloads can spike,
to do all this image processing
and deep learning inference using TensorFlow.
And that allows us to iterate rapidly
and to develop new, powerful
machine learning models
in a really cost-effective way.
So let me give you one
really powerful example of a model.
So here we built a unified,
high-dimensional representation latent space
to help us identify the most likely drugs
to work for a given disease,
before we even run that test in the lab.
So here I'm showing just a small subset
of this latent space data,
in a simplified 3D graphic,
so essentially taking thousands of dimensions
and turning that into something
that's visually interpretable by humans.
The red dots indicate
the results of adding disease
to human cells in our lab,
and the blue dots represent
a separate addition of drugs
to cells in the lab.
The closer two dots are,
the more similar their effects
on human cells, and vice versa.
So it turns out that drugs tend to cluster
on the opposite side of the latent space
from the drugs that they work on,
so the diseases that they can treat.
So while not a perfect predictor,
this means that we have a data pattern
to help us identify drugs
that are likely to be effective.
Or, to put it another way,
these blue dot drugs you see here
are likely to be effective
against the red dot disease
on the opposite side.
This is really powerful,
because it means that for the first time
we do not have to test every drug
against every disease in the laboratory.
We can predict, already on the cloud,
which drugs are likely to work.
And this is the type of approach
that saves our scientists tons of time
and tons of resources.
And it's also an example
of the kind of capability
Recursion is building out
in order to be able to exponentially
increase the efficiency in drug discovery.
And that brings us
to our final step, step three.
Our team of biologists validate and follow up
on all of our results.
Robotics, machine learning models,
and human biologists
then work hand in hand, together,
to speed up all the steps
of the drug discovery pipeline
from in vitro to in vivo,
and then, eventually, human medical trials.
In fact, using this new formula,
Recursion already has one drug
cleared by the FDA
for human medical trials,
and we have a pipeline
of dozens of other drugs behind it,
in just five short years.
This is a tremendous volume,
not just for a small startup
like for Recursion,
but for any biopharma company.
We are on a journey to decode biology
and to find cures
for today's untreatable diseases.
I hope you are inspired to join us.
Thank you.
(applause)
♪ (music) ♪
Alright! Hey!
Alright! Was that a fun time, or what?
Yeah!
So I want to recap.
Our promise to you, our commitment to you,
the first is around innovation,
the second is around openness,
and the third is about
being part of a community.
Now I've got something to announce
that I want you to pay attention to.
I'm incredibly excited to announce
that our community is running DevFests--
community-organized developer events--
in 500 cities, starting basically
in a couple of weeks.
So I hope you all find a local one.
Get plugged into that local community!
I want to thank all of you.
Thanks for your participation.
Thanks for your feedback and your challenge.
Now we're going to do something...
... Another thing I want to tell you
that we're going to do now,
is we're going to officially announce
a save-the-date for the next Next:
April 9-11 in San Francisco, right here.
♪ (music) ♪